surfshark sponsored today's show what
does surf shot do they make virtual
private networks just for you there are
many of them out there to keep you
anonymous online or to let you go to
another country in the world now the
fact is you've probably heard a lot
about this on youtube right brian all
the youtubers are talking about it
they're all going oh i love surf shark
it's amazing because it is right if you
want to go somewhere else in the world
watch some of their netflix what some of
their other players that they've got out
there maybe you like a bit of hbo maybe
you like a bit of peacock in america i
know i do love the peacock yeah all you
got to do is get yourself on surf shark
it's 83
off right now with three months for free
and there's a 30-day money-back
guarantee which means that if you don't
like it get your money back all you got
to do is use our code which is jordy
jordy jordy
is in the description down there you
know what to do yeah go and do it yeah
right remember you want to be anonymous
online you want to get somewhere else in
the world virtually there you go go with
surf shark they're the best and they
sponsor the show enjoy it but for now
it's true news baby
[Music]
welcome back to true news we've just
gotten back from a lovely holiday
difficult landing people are watching
playing struggling or as we call it
death cam how many people are watching
this about a hundred thousand hundred
and twenty five thousand hundred twenty
six thousand people was watching playing
struggling the land because you sick
want to see people die yeah absolutely
the best thing about this whole stream
the commentary
hit that subscribe button folks go on
because this is the kind of stuff
that we love here on big jet tv we love
the possibility that people could be
seriously injured or die in a jet crash
here at big jet tv don't forget to hit
that subscribe button how does he react
if if a plane actually just goes down
here we go here we go oh [__]
look at that
to be fit oh yeah look at it
that pilot must literally be going [__]
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] i wonder
if it's added pressure that he's being
live streamed because as we know the
pressures of that yeah you know
sometimes just talking it's difficult
put you on a live stream people [__] the
bed yeah speaking of which biggie bicky
you've absolutely [__] the bed please
that stinks that's disgusting don't get
a frenchie look at this do not buy one
don't get one seeing this guys stink
especially when you feed them your
leftovers i still love you though
someone said they're earning their pay
today some of these
comments are the stupidest are really
like exposing the inner workings of
people's brains because yeah as if a
pilot doesn't normally earn his video
like generally speaking their job is to
keep us all [__] safe and not only
that that guy who says they're earning
their pay today is definitely the kind
of person that when a plane lands he
goes yep brilliant brilliant nailed that
one of the things they're saying is like
in block capitals butter is it like
smooth smooth that is lovely to be fair
um good see chris
you're one of the
150 000 people doing this
on a friday where you should be at work
or whatever some of you probably are at
work i'd be surprised if anyone watching
this isn't a loser so that includes us
if you were watching it you were a loser
imagine you're trying to join the mile
high club under these circumstances
though if anything it helps
you i just sit there and the plane lifts
them up and down true yeah
okay here we go the uh
this is when it starts to get really
a little bit larry right now imagine
that this plane crashes and he's
commentated this before is his channel
all about this it's called big jet tv
brian i don't think he's covering much
else he's got less altitude to work with
so decisions must be made he manages to
hype every single play in landing yeah
he's not even giving me any really sort
of technical commentary here what he's
basically saying he doesn't know the
captain if you're not a pilot otherwise
he'd be doing it he'd have an actual job
you know what i mean instead of just
the guy who sits and watches videos well
yeah i mean true this is where the skill
of the pilot really comes in
earning their salary cash back wow this
guy is [__] serious oh he doesn't
look anything like i thought he would
look oh no he very much looks a bit like
that welsh guy do you remember that
welsh guy who drinks a lot i got in an
absolute right state last night hey
folks slight change of plan uh no longer
flying out to keflavik with ice and
there turns out my commentary was
putting the pilot off on the flight and
i wasn't allowed on the plane this is
where he really earns his salary
anyway speaking of huge crashes that
come from the sky kanye west is
divorcing kim kardashian is kim
kardashian divorcing him she's divorcing
him right okay he's also breaking up
with his girlfriend good because that
wasn't making any good music uh julia
fox uh somebody remember her as the
white girl with the big dumper from
uncut gems
right look great in uncut gems
right lately um looked a bit strange
unusual makeup someone shot her in the
face with a paint gun
a little bit she posted a little message
after everyone was like ah kanye's left
you now now you're irrelevant again and
she's like not i know you want to see a
sad lonely woman crying on a plane by
myself while someone live streams it can
commentate absolutely um but it's not
true it's not true see me for what i am
which is a number one hustler i came up
y'all and not only that but kanye and i
are on good terms i have love for him
but i wasn't in love with him jesus
christ what do you think i am 12 years
old yeah yeah because being in love
that's for 12 year olds that's okay yeah
you can get cooties if you're in love
you want to be careful about julia you
might catch kanye's
shagging this is the bit that worries me
and she was like and for the record the
only time i cried in 2022 was on
february 6th on my dead best friend's
forever birthday wow now that last bit
she's clearly bothered but she's acting
like she's not bothered i get that
sometimes you have to do that in life
but also doesn't sound like someone who
thinks logically she is someone who
thinks logically there because she's
she's writing a book now apparently
she's only been in one decent movie as a
bit of a side piece you know she was
literally her side piece uh yeah she was
with a celebrity for a few months and a
couple of months even it's not really
enough for a boot there i'll give kanye
credit he proved he can make another
celebrity like that when she turned up
with him everyone was [__] talking
about her so he's made this girl's
career so you're damn right you should
be on good terms with him because
without him no one would know who the
[__] you are so kim kardashian obviously
filed for divorce now she's getting
[__] down by pete davidson hey you
guys
if you don't know he's a scrawny little
white comedian whose father died in 9
11. previously he'd made a lot of jokes
about kanye and when he went through his
donald trump thing he was ripping into
him and now he's poking his wife
so um turns out making fun of mental
health is comedy the one thing about
kanye that always makes me within two
minds of whether or not it's a real
meltdown or a publicity stunt is he goes
silent for ages and then he's got an
album coming out and then he attacks
everyone love it yes the 22nd of feb
kanye so if you're friends with kanye by
any chance and you're watching this and
he's got an album coming out probably
just sort of lay low today we need to
talk about how kanye west is going off
on kim kardashian p davidson billy
eilish kid cudi and so many others he is
currently trending right now and it is
crazy can i ask you do you feel
comfortable with people using words like
crazy and stuff around this because it
is very much mental health related and
at one point he was genius right and he
made some amazing music that's what i
remember him for but now he has serious
mental health problems and no one's able
to help him it's a very difficult
situation this they're so famous so rich
so powerful nobody can really tell these
people what to do so when one of them is
in the throes of another mental health
breakdown who the [__] comes to
stop him or to say no you need to put
the phone down and start acting a bit
more like his mother isn't here and we
all know how important she was to him so
where do where do they turn it's it's a
nightmare in the very public light of
day kanye west is sharing all his
thoughts he's sharing some of his
grievances and he's clearly a very angry
guy who's doing very toxic things he's
trying to shame his wife bring a woman
back to him who really does deserve
independence and does want to be away
from him and he's also bringing his
stuff too pete's probably the least uh
toxic thing he's doing here and the
final thing is talking about his kids in
public is probably one of the worst
things you can do because these people
don't have that decision to say they
love their dad they're never going to go
dad stop well they don't understand
because they're so young
they're getting dragged into this
publicly when they're not in control of
their own lives yet right and i feel
that when kanye first got with kim i
remember obviously this was after his
brilliant albums he paid all these
tributes to kim the final bit of um lost
in the world is a poem about kim but he
finally got the girl this is a great
story and he's had to be in this world
where he was a very real artist where he
suddenly became into like a very
synthetic fake world i can imagine those
two things would mess with your head
because kanye was brought up in the real
hard times of life i mean he was in the
ghetto and you got kim who wasn't kim
has always been a part of this plastic
world right and full of money and that
doesn't mean she hasn't experienced any
hardship her father's famous for the one
of the biggest lies of all time one of
the biggest public lies of all time is
that o.j simpson murdered a man of
course we all know he was truly innocent
what am i saying oj oj didn't murder
anyone sorry
although kanye is behaving like an
unstable person right now which clearly
he is we don't know what is being said
to him behind closed doors right which
could be also triggering that yeah it
does feel like by kim and them not
coming out publicly it's as if they're
trying to calm it down and he is
struggling with a way of being heard and
he feels like lashing out publicly is
the way he gets attention and heard and
respect absolutely and i also think one
sign of a toxic relationship is when
someone tries to go public is when
someone tries to show other people hey
this is what this person's building and
we do see this on a lower level in
everyday life on social media when
people are lashing out at their partners
or i'm sick of this i'm sick of that but
this is on a level that we've never seen
before absolutely in a relationship in
in history this isn't just a
relationship that kanye has with only
kim there's chris jenner involved
there's the sisters involved they're a
very tight-knit family but they also
they have an army of pr experts behind
them whereas kanye is not savvy like
that he is going to make himself look
crap he called her chris jon
at one point like it's an indication as
to what the relationship is like between
chris and the rest of the family and
let's face it like these guys are famous
they you know they've been through a lot
to make this money god have they taken a
lot of dick one of them is a potential
billionaire so they've got a lot to lose
here kanye played a massive role in that
actually because he legitimized the
whole family yeah because he was the one
with talent and actual genius who came
in and yeah he did legitimize them but
now they're like okay we've squeezed the
juice out of you right they've taken
everything from kanye at this point and
i don't want to defend these terrible
actions but i've spoken to a few people
who've worked on keeping up with the
kardashians and they speak about the
level of control the ndas that are
signed all the privacy that's around so
many of these matters when you've put
your real life out there for years brian
your real life and then you come back
and go whoa wait a minute don't share
this part of our lives i feel there's an
element of hypocrisy there whether or
not you're gonna be with him or not he's
the father of your children i think
washing her hands of him giving what
he's going through right now makes it
i'm not saying it's the wrong decision
but it must be a painful situation to be
in for everyone here's the other aspect
we know that when kim kardashian or
kylie or any of them don't want to be
photographed by the press they're not
photographed by the press kim's not an
idiot she knows there's back deck back
ways into hotels she knows she doesn't
have to leave in public with pete
davidson she knows she doesn't have to
be pictured with him but these are very
public photo opportunities which are
being engineered by kim and her pr
people if you don't want to be seen with
pete davidson as a celebrity don't leave
somewhere with with pete davidson as a
celebrity and this is the thing you know
who kanye is you know what he's like and
you know that publicly dating the guy
who humiliated him on saturday night
live is going to trigger the [__] right
go with this guy so you're telling me
that basically and i get it right it's
not someone he respects yeah you pick
one of the worst people or one of the
best people depending on your
perspective yeah if you're trying to get
a reaction out of him ding ding ding
ding ding right you've hit the jackpot
yeah kanye really started to turn heads
when he felt like it was so wrong that
he was not present at his daughter
chicago's birthday party he wasn't being
let in he didn't know where the address
of it was i get why kanye was pissed off
about not being invited to the
daughter's birthday and he made a huge
deal about this yeah but also like you
saw billionaires with companies and
people like could we not get an
immediate uh to talk to and arrange two
birthday parties i mean let's be honest
they've got enough money for that i
don't know about that mate this is a
pretty big birthday party yeah it's
chaos clearly there's just a real
breakdown here yeah i'm just wishing my
daughter a public happy birthday i
wasn't allowed to know
where her party was i'm just putting
this online because i need y'all support
i didn't call
kim
text the nannies i got on the phone with
tristan i love that all of the
boyfriends sort of have a little support
group together within this is like
tristan thompson they're in a what's up
group actually tristan thompson's going
i'm [__] miserable
yeah we love the [__] at the start but
now it's pure misery there's got to be
some reason that they stick around for
this [__] for men like kanye who can
have any beautiful woman to find a
beautiful woman who's then business
savvy smart intelligent powerful he's
actually getting lured in by all that
[__] you know
before you realize it you're getting
checkmated because they are experts in
the game of life and you're just a music
guy i got on the phone with tristan he
he said he asked chloe won't nobody give
me the address to my daughter's birthday
party right now yeah chloe yeah kanye
asked him why the event
oh [__] chloe ain't in the house because
i slept with three other women
my whole schedule is
all based around me being able to take
my kids to school me being there for
them making sure that i'm in a life
that's the whole point of having money
there's a lot of people that's not in a
position with ain't got no voice i spoke
about this on true news before my dad
has bipolar disorder so some of kanye's
like posts i'm just like yeah that's
like that's the bipolar you can see how
out of touch he can be with reality
sometimes but when you see him like this
he wins you over because you're like oh
there's a common sense talking guy who
just wants to take his kids to school
how could you not root for that but this
isn't always him and that's important to
remember right and there is yeah there's
a lot of good and bad
and he later said that he had to get the
address of the party from travis scott
genius travis scott that's why he's
defending travis scott against billy
eilish because travis is his boy yeah
all right i get it but also i i love the
idea that someone went who the [__]
told kanye that and travis is going who
knows kanye takes social media goes
thanks travis scott for the address of
your party is like i didn't it wasn't he
was later seen having attended the party
those who are dressed as evil geniuses
it is mad that even for a children's
birthday party they still dress like
this kim and north if you guys did not
know have a shared tick tock account
where the comments are always turned off
but the two of them post together and
kanye made it known that he is not happy
about this at all he posted a screenshot
of one of north's tick tocks since this
is my first divorce i need to know what
i should do about my daughter being put
on tick tock against my will that is
slightly toxic behavior you can't tell
everyone else in the family exactly what
they have to do and as a parent i get it
you want to have privacy for your kids
this is very different to any normal
parent who doesn't have the fame there's
another element another layer to this
the horses [__] bolted me i mean you
married the most famous woman in the
world arguably and then repeatedly
shared so many images so many videos the
pair of them of these children in their
upbringing they never had a chance at
privacy true privacy ever and that if
user made a decision from that from day
one then yes that could have been done
but no chance not now the horse is gone
i do think that he probably isn't that
bothered about the tick-tock thing truly
after all of the evidence to the
contrary i think this is just a way of
him trying to paint kim out as the bad
guy right which is never healthier at
this point america saw you trying to
kidnap my daughter on her birthday by
not providing the address i think he
understands kidnapping no i get that um
well and that just shows how in his head
things can blow up like we're talking
about him not being invited somewhere
and then to him it's like kidnapping
like that's how and that's again the the
mental illness coming out potentially or
it just could be him being an [__]
and trying to paint her out in a bad
light and that's part of the problem
here is how harshly you judge someone
having a mental illness should not make
you exempt from you know having to
behave like a reasonable person but at
the same time how harsh we are on him
it's gotta be carefully measured kanye
has expressed a number of times in the
last year honestly that he does want him
back and to be together again and this
post the other day on instagram read god
please bring our family back together if
you're listening god strike pete
davidson down just to be clear i don't
think that would make a difference
because i think kim is well and truly
done with this guy yeah and his
inability to accept that it doesn't come
across well does it i mean what what
what are you doing if this was one of
your mates that you'd go proof delete
that because you're looking like a
[__] desperado yeah i'd imagine at
that that's part of it you love your
family but the time has gone she's a
free woman to do what she wants i do
think part of kanye is very much playing
the game as well when he goes america
seeing you what he a lot of this is also
for our benefit sure it's to win the
people back and like at the nfl super
bowl for example he was booed around the
stadium partly he is aware of that he's
not coming off well he only needs to try
and win people back and by being a
victim he's hopeful that that will work
and let's be real he's learned from the
master you do not spend 10 years married
to kim kardashian and not learn a thing
or two about pr manipulation he has also
been expressing his major dislike for
pete davidson of all the people who your
missus could end up going with right
after you publicly gotta be high on the
list for like worst nightmare apparently
a lot of women in the industry find him
quite charming when they meet him he's
quite sort of harmless there's not much
to him which is sort of like very
intimidating he yeah he's a skinny
little comedian who makes people laugh
but like it's like well that's the guy
i'd rather her level up she had a type
of before i don't feel he fits into the
that's the yeah like she's been with
some like stud athletes right and then
she's just gone for this like he's just
feeble is what i'm saying people she
this man is fee but then part of you
thinks why would she go for a guy who's
like that and you think kanye intense
stressful last 10 years constantly
managing his like sort of your mental
health
and then you've got this laid-back
entertainer who just wants to crack
jokes and [__] you every now and then
she's like actually this is pretty chill
this so maybe she's just gone the
complete opposite way after kanye wants
something light-hearted which is a good
rebound it's rebounding and kanye felt
absolutely betrayed by him on instagram
he even posted this photo from a time
where kim and kanye went to dinner with
kid cudi and timothy chalamet and pete
davidson and he crossed out pete
davidson's face from this photo whoa
just crop him how weird so just crop it
kanye was like friendly enough with pete
that he went to dinner with him well uh
kid cudi was friends with pete and
obviously you know if you roll in these
celebrity circles there's a bit of the
incest so you're sitting having dinner
with this guy one minute and then a few
years later he's banging your wife by
the way man i'm [__] your wife
i'm very community oriented i love my
friends i love my family the reason i
ask cuddy to at least speak to skeet who
is pete is because for years cudi always
made it seem like it was me and him
against everyone again kanye the victim
in his head here now that doesn't mean
that's reality kanye then posts
something about um pete sent intimate
photos with ariana to mac miller with a
way to end the rap as hopes of
rekindling the relationship with her so
pete has been used in another
high-profile breakup he's he's a
homewrecker a picture of pete davidson
uh eating what looks like popcorn
kanye's comment no you will never meet
my children when he clearly has i mean
he's definitely he definitely met the
kids here's kanye west uh after he was
kidnapped by
terrorists he's not hacked this is the
sort of [__] that makes you look insane
this is the thing about kanye right just
one one thing i do need to say in terms
of people who he's been aggressive too
uh billy eilish taylor swift pete
davidson white women kanye's not exactly
a classic rapper a lot of rappers are
brave and they want to like have it out
with another alpha one of the main
reasons he's going at pete davidson is
because he genuinely thinks he could
probably have him if kim was with like
50 cent i don't think he's giving it the
biggen like this i think he's probably
quite quiet right now so i don't know if
bully's the right word but soft [__] he
picks his battles very carefully right
yeah
yeah but beyonce did have one of the
best videos of all time speaking of
people in trouble with their exes prince
andrew claims he paid some money to a
woman that he barely even knows we all
remember the interview where the old
dirty bastard uh basically was lying
about doesn't remember if he met her or
not all of that [__] wasn't lying says
here he wasn't lying he's settled so
that they don't have to go to court for
the price of 12 million now whatever
evidence was there it was enough to pay
12 million to shut this woman up prince
andrew here pictured as you know a man
of honor sort of looking down
remembering the troops those kind of
things they're trying to save this
fucker's image the whole way they
avoided it the queen to help pay he
hasn't got his own money he hasn't had a
[__] weekend job since he's been born
and all of that he's been saving up for
just such an occasion yeah like the
queen gets all her [__] money from us
we're literally funding a pedo i really
hope this is the generation to take down
the royals literally these guys are
above the law there's certain people
they can just do what the [__] they want
i'm here she thought you'd just die time
travel from somewhere else oh i'm in a
room i'm wearing clothes oh my goodness
good morning
how are you
well as you can see i can't move i oh
many congratulations from the start of
your uh jubilee year and morning must be
so [__] boring for her every day she
has to go through all these receiving
congratulations and thanks a lot for
this sometimes she might just want to go
can we just stick cory on and just relax
for 20 minutes let's not feel too sorry
for her she just paid 12 million to get
her son off the hook for [__] being
the nuns yeah but that wasn't her she
still loves him even if your son's going
around nonsense you're still bloody go
oh i still love your son i don't think
she ever did i watched the uh crown stop
thinking the crown is a real
representative
the kids actually prince andrew was a
favorite that's the ironic thing when
she first heard about this she went oh
andy what have you done you've got the
whole family into trouble now oh here i
am again he told her and then 12 minutes
later she went good to see you andrew i
hope you're well he went mom i've been
here the whole time do you not remember
what i've just taught what were we
saying again oh so i was just saying
about it
i've got a big project i need some money
for oh yeah sign away whatever you need
we're looking after the kids it's gonna
cost 12 million 12 million it's uh it's
to help a young girl in another country
well you all know i love send spending
money to those women out there help any
woman who's in trouble oh she was very
much in trouble mum there's a chance she
could be dead soon actually yeah listen
we can't ignore prince andrew on the
front page of uh all the papers this
morning as much as they [__] tried
the queen may be contributing two
million pounds of her own money which
would be a donation to virginia's
charity it wasn't andrew's choice or
anyone on the royal family's choice to
give it to charity it was actually
virginia's choice to give it to charity
so this woman received the 12 million
and then immediately passed it on to
charity the point is it was never prince
andrew's choice for it to go to charity
she should have kept it she should have
kept it quiet yeah she should have kept
it bit of a mug absolutely yeah she's
mugged herself off there lots and lots
of calls within the press today linda
saying we need to know we as the public
have a right to know the palace of a
duty to tell us apparently not despite
the fact that we pay for them to sit on
a gold throne i mean if it's money
coming out of their banks then that's
fair enough it's all public money you
[__] oh i'm sorry i was thinking about a
lovely woman but this this just she was
really good in birds of a feather though
i did love that yeah do you remember
that yeah it was a good show yeah and
then they should be paying for it i
don't think the public i don't think we
should be using our money to pay for
what he's allegedly done oh she's got a
little smile though she knows he did it
though oh she knows it's just very
confusing really to know what is their
money and what is our money because
again my love it's not confusing at all
it's all our money they literally take
money from our taxes every [__] year
all our money if you ever look into the
refurbishments that they have done on
their properties hundreds of millions of
pounds oh brian you should look it's
beautiful what they've had done recently
the fittings oh clearly all of their
money comes from inheritance to so yeah
yeah and inherited of course from a
previous generation that also took all
of our money i know i stand up for harry
and megan in a sea of people who don't
you're just such a bloody trooper you're
a martyr
prince harry is constantly berated
challenged criticized and yet here is
the queen bailing andrew out of this
situation but you can't
thank you
the queen could at some point just
stepped in and went you know we've got
control over the press do you think we
could take the heat off the guy who's
left the family like do you not think
she's got anything to do with this i
think of the queen at the back of
buckingham palace with a cigarette going
yeah he's a little [__] oh but don't put
that in your paper yeah she wanders off
back into a shadow with these people oh
i walked into a wall oh here i am i'm
here do you think that this has
diminished trust in the royal family
carol why do we have to trust them
they're the royal family i just want
them to be there i don't care actually i
don't care how many people they molest
just get on with it you know do we have
the right to know where the money's
coming from do we have the right not to
want to know because i don't care where
it's coming from if it's the public
money or or if it's any money we don't
even know it's 12 million do we we don't
know that we don't know it's 12 million
it's literally reported as 12 million we
don't know we still don't know what
happened dude we don't actually know we
can't join some dot's love
you know we've got a really good [__]
idea at this moment
was she on a talk show where
you are paid to be somewhat clued up
about the situation well we just don't
know we'll never know next topic every
topic she goes well we just don't know
i'm not in charge of the budget at itv
yeah but let me just say probably could
get more for your money guys what i was
saying was the other night i was
watching jurassic park i turned to
husband i went this is a great
documentary he went it's not a
documentary love i went i don't know
what's true anymore
elsewhere in other news trisha peters
has some happy news for us
she pissed on matt i really hope it's a
girl no lad wants to go to school where
all the all the lads when you're like 14
going seeing this video of your mother
just uh eating this cake yeah we're
happy for trisha paytas for having a
baby because apparently yeah she was
told before she couldn't have kids i get
we're happy for her but even roaches
have kids
it's not really an achievement so let's
look at her most viewed videos real
quick just to give you an idea of what
we're getting into here do dogs even
have brains says trisha paytas um
profoundly according to the chase this
is not a mentally stable person right
then her being in charge of looking
after a child does worry you a bit as a
man you get told a few things by your
family like look for this and a woman
look for that in a woman she doesn't
have many of those
my son actually does eat better than
this imagine all the grease and tomato
all over her face after that though
imagine all the jizz on all those men's
stomachs who just watched this oh what
are you doing oh look at that you're
applying it like a foundation i think
she's rubbing it on her face more like a
penis i think that's part of this you
know what i mean spiky penis my god
she's gonna be a mother laurence paul me
feels bad about this because i'm
criticizing her and i don't really want
to be she's having a happy moment right
but like what the [__] is this kid hope
in life right it doesn't mean that we
have to go absolutely fantastic stuff if
anything it would make us two-faced you
do need some guidance in life some some
sensible heads right
as a child someone who's as erratic and
as up and down and as treachery as this
it's a worry isn't it
we watch this space you know
we hope that the kid grows up to be well
adjusted and everything works out fine
sometimes they go the other she's got
money she can look after it with
financially but you just think where are
we going with this it seems that
trisha's preempted elements of this and
she said i've been working on myself for
a long time and this past year i've been
able to regulate my emotions practice
wise mind wise mind daily set boundaries
and disengage when needed i get that
i've been a mess for a long time but the
change started long before i got
pregnant people just don't want to see
it you can't behave for a sustained
period of time the way she has and then
expect us to believe you've changed
because of a [__] tweet it just ain't
enough i get that you know so she's
saying people don't want to say it it's
like no there's a lot of evidence to
suggest one thing and not a lot of
evidence to suggest that you've sorted
yourself out so good luck we wish you
the best
for you
don't [__] this kid's life up you've got
this and go out and do it don't talk
about it be it right all right wow
that's [__] inspirational hey gotcha
right of course somebody can't do this
is floyd money mayweather when it comes
to partying with that said money uh he
often says to people do you want to get
paid i can't and he's done that again
with logan paul so logan is taking him
to court yeah floyd um smart investments
uh mayweather who is not a good
businessman hence why he's still having
the fight at the age he is and having to
do silly little boxing matches against
this fella in dubai now money kicks
he's called he's just a rich kid the guy
isn't even in shape he's not a boxer in
any way we've seen that logan has been
very public about it so before we fought
we were kind of willing to do whatever
now after the fact we're kind of
shooting ourselves in the foot and then
floyd replied this comes with the
territory i mean if you do business with
floyd and you don't have everything
locked in a way that conor mcgregor and
the ufc had it is gonna be difficult and
he is going to do things that are sneaky
and shady such as sell pay-per-view
rights to a different country and not
even tell you about it and make sure he
pockets it all now people say great
businessman no great businessmen don't
[__] everyone over on their path floyd
mayweather is the equivalent of don king
but wearing boxing gloves like just a
bad person who's willing to [__]
everybody over around him right and be a
little weasel and run off with the bag
but logan did his fair share of the work
to bring all that money in but because
floyd is probably has issues with the
tax man which is exactly why for conor
mcgregor by the way but people forget
about the fact that a large amount of
his conor mcgregor money went straight
at the tax man because he was in debt to
him right but again great businessman
narrative it's just rubbish right and
and to go alongside that he's now saying
ah the real problem here is that logan
doesn't know how the fight business
works all right basically i'm still
working i'm still waiting on checks from
seven or eight years ago you've got to
be patient in this business logan like
he's absolutely lying here and i i get
that there will be some trickling money
in from previous work he's done look we
can't trust this guy man the guy
literally he beats women and if you look
at his smart investments you look at
entrepreneurs on social media they're
posting about their many businesses do
you know what floyd mayweather posts
about strippers that you can see it as
one strip club to be fair is one of his
many businesses i mean it is his main
business but he only really advertises
this one business because the others are
just doing too well together i mean he
doesn't even need this doesn't even need
to um of course brian what he does say
is just be happy with the biggest payday
you ever got in your life i would be i
guess says logan if i ever got it i mean
this is just to be clear like logan paul
at one point made 30 million pounds in a
year from merchandise that's not even
including all the other things he does
right like the bottom line is you make
an agreement with a guy you stick to it
pay the [__] money thanks a lot for
watching guys really appreciate it um
you know see you again here for true
news you keep asking us to keep going
with this so i guess we're gonna have to
um that way it works i don't know if
that's how it works hopefully there's
more weirdness in the media because
otherwise we have to get serious about
[__] don't forget look after yourselves
look after the ones you love keep it
here on twitter youtube channel loads of
podcasts coming up and we will see you
on the next one